what we can see here is uh three lines
which are representing those areas
which are currently tier four areas so
places like london
and that's the dark black line and you
can see that since september
there has been a a rise and then in
november when the restrictions came in
and we had if you like the original
covid you can see that starts to decline
but then fairly soon afterwards and
particularly the start of this month you
can see
an extraordinarily rapid rise cases
moving upwards
um the next the dotted line the purple
dotted line are those areas which are
now
moving into tier four and you can see
the
same shape of curve here what we what
we're trying to do
is identify where that rapid increase is
coming which is most likely due to the
new variant
and you can see that it's a parallel
line to
the areas where we currently know have
very high proportions
of new variant in the cases detected
what's equally important i think is to
look at the green dotted line and these
are
areas in the rest of england obviously a
month previously we've tended to see
very dark colours
at the north northwest northeast and
what you can see there is the rise
during september october the november
restrictions coming in and quite a
significant drop in that dotted green
line
so against our old version of covid if
you like
the restrictions had effect and what
we're dealing with now
is almost two different patterns one for
the new variant
and one for the old next slide please
and uh here uh this is uh clearer i
think in this one so these are cases
uh identify the proportion of cases uh
which are positive
for covid19 from november and then
running in through to the middle of
december
the dark purple line is cases which are
new variant compatible
and the green line are the cases so in
some ways this is reflecting the green
and purple lines
on the original map and what you can see
again is that the
original version of kovid is been
brought down from november you can see
quite a sharp decline in cases
and the leveling off but a very rapid
rise
in the new variant cases which are
moving forward at pace